So, where was W'Kabi? The character's absence from
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" had more to do
with the busy schedule of the actor playing
him than the character himself, it seems.
In the months leading up to the November 2022
release of "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever,"
Marvel Cinematic Universe fans learned relatively
little about the film's plot or cast. It also
wasn't totally clear how "Wakanda Forever"
would ultimately handle the tragic 2020 death
of Chadwick Boseman, who played King T'Challa,
the title character from 2018's "Black Panther."
But fans were comforted by the information
they did get. Marvel confirmed that many of
the stars of "Black Panther" would return in
"Wakanda Forever," including Letitia Wright,
who plays Shuri; Lupita Nyong'o,
who plays Nakia; and Martin Freeman,
who portrays CIA agent Everett Ross. The movie
also introduces a number of new characters,
such as Tenoch Huerta's Namor, Dominique Thorne's
Riri Williams, and Michaela Cole's Aneka.
But not everyone from the first movie returns
in the sequel. Indeed, one of the most memorable
supporting characters from the first "Black
Panther" film is discussed, but isn't present.
In a Tweet that is no longer public, Rotten
Tomatoes Awards Editor Jacqueline Coley first
revealed that actor Daniel Kaluuya did not
film any scenes as W'Kabi for "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever." Coley said that Kaluuya
mentioned in an interview that he was
unable to reprise his "Black Panther"
role because of a scheduling conflict
with director Jordan Peele's film "Nope."
Variety later confirmed this to be true.
"It's a shame. But it's, um--
I'm so happy they're doing it."
Kaluuya plays one of the lead characters in
"Nope," and the film is his first collaboration
with Peele since 2017's "Get Out." It seems
the monumental re-teaming of actor and director
meant Kaluuya had to pass up the opportunity
to appear in "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
Nevertheless, "Wakanda Forever"
weathers Kaluuya's absence well,
tying it into the events of the original
2018 film. In that movie, after being
initially introduced as a major supporter of King
T'Challa, Kaluuya's W'Kabi turns on the king,
as well as his lover Okoye, to support Erik
"Killmonger" Stevens' take over of Wakanda.
"Everything is on schedule."
"Have the spies been alerted?"
"Yes. Some resistance to our new mission."
Of course, Killmonger's coup ultimately
fails, and Okoye eventually confronts
W'Kabi on the battlefield. W'Kabi has
no choice but to surrender to her.
"Would you kill me, my love?"
"For Wakanda?
Without question."
So even if Kaluuya had been able to appear in
"Wakanda Forever," it's clear W'Kabi's actions
in the first movie would likely have resulted
in him having a reduced role in the sequel.
W'Kabi is absent from "Wakanda Forever,"
but he does come up in dialogue once,
in the scene in which Queen Ramonda strips
Okoye of her position as general of the
Dora Milaje. Ramonda essentially implies
that he's been imprisoned for treason.
Speaking to CinemaBlend, "Black Panther"
and "Wakanda Forever" director Ryan Coogler
revealed just what W'Kabi is up to during
the events of "Wakanda Forever," saying,
From the sound of it, W'Kabi is currently
something of an afterthought as far as the
ongoing story of the "Black Panther"
universe is concerned. But Coogler
has confirmed that W'Kabi is both alive and
in Wakanda. That leaves room for his return
in either a future "Black Panther" film or
Coogler's upcoming Wakanda-based Disney+ show,
should Kaluuya's schedule once again
allow him to reprise his MCU character.